All we say to America is, "Be true to what you said on paper."
If I lived in China or even Russia, or any totalitarian country,...
...maybe, I could understand some of these illegal injunctions.
Maybe, I could understand the denial of certain, basic First Amendment privileges,...
...because they hadn't committed themselves to that over there.
But somewhere, I read of the freedom of assembly.
Somewhere, I read of the freedom of speech.
Somewhere, I read of the freedom of press.
Somewhere, I read that the greatness of America is the right to protest for right.
And so just as I say, we aren't gonna let any dogs or water hoses turn us around.
We aren't gonna let any injunction turn us around.
Well, I don't know what will happen now.
We've got some difficult days ahead,...
...but it really doesn't matter with me now,...
...because I've been to the mountaintop,...
...I don't mind.
Like anybody, I would like to live a long life.
Longevity has its place,...
...but I'm not concerned about that now.
I just wanna do God's will.
And he's allowed me to go up to the mountain,...
...and I've looked over,...
...and I've seen the promised land.
I may not get there with you,...
...but I want you to know tonight...
...that we, as a people, will get to the promised land!
So, I'm happy tonight.
I'm not worried about anything.
I'm not fearing any man!
Mine eyes have seen the glory of the coming of the Lord.